a beautiful wedded couple wait but and
barnyard animal revenge it's episode 18
of IMG
[Music]
Jesus walks on water so there is a way
to hide from it and combine Miss Piggy
and Chumlee and you get sesame street
fighter oh yeah there are stickers
CollegeHumor calm brought us the best of
trick photography like this impossibly
long arm a bathroom self-shot Budokan
and moving on to sum up 2010
buzzfeed.com collected the 40 best mug
shots of the year we've got the most
enthusiastic the thickest neck the best
cap male and the best cap female we
enjoy the rest immature calm put
together 2010's most loaded images
including Riley the saucy birthday dog
here's the world's largest bucket of
fried chicken and the largest goldfish
but let's go smallest this sculpture of
Charlie Chaplin is standing I'm serious
on an eyelash Willard Wiggin makes these
tiny sculptures by hand that has to
perform his work between heartbeats
because at this scale your own blood
pressure affects accuracy but here's
some doorbells via do-while you can't
miss an enter button a creepy squishable
eyeball doorbell and of course a deer
but when photos are taken at just the
right time from the right angle that can
raise a lot of questions sometimes
they're on purpose sometimes they're
accidental and sometimes it's just a guy
who is he on everyone if you want to
take a nap while still looking alert and
grab some sleep safe tape this clear
tape has eyes printed on it so when it's
on your face you go from this to this
great underwear for men keyboards Hello
Kitty and bhayya the clearly dope
Pinocchio get it reddit was incredible
this week when you're snowed in dig
yourself a new fridge and here's what
happens when you sleep on your phone can
camouflage ever get better than this
well yes yes it can
here's a mall prank we should all be
doing and here are instructions for
folding a five-dollar bill to cap
blinkin for a closer look follow the
link in this video's description where
links to everything can be
and now here's a view from atop the
Eiffel Tower a couple weeks ago a
friendly do-gooder cleared some of the
snow away but just some of it
that picture was actually recommended by
a Vsauce err just like you
facebook.com/vsaucegaming is your ticket
to being just as awesome
for instance Aiden Murphy used an up all
night trick on our Facebook page and
Ryan Tim introduced me to an ATM that
makes no sense at all keep submitting
and sharing awesome stuff but for things
you can actually own yourself go check
out episode 2 of loot on vsauce2 and let
me know in the comments below what you
wish there were two of and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]